[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans siro par
les sports les missions ne surtout pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local au programme aujourd'hui
comme toujours des analyses techniques
des décryptages et surtout une dose de
bonne humeur pour m'accompagner nos
chroniqueurs sont avec nous sur ce
plateau et ce n'était pas simple de les
avoir dans cette émission ils sont
pressentis pour arriver dans le nouveau
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron
présentation en musique on commence à ma
droite il fait son grand retour après
une émission à d'absence attivi noah est
un accro à tous les sports cyclisme
roller course à chris voile et j'en
fasse le capitaine ya dujarrier fait son
come back il sera avec nous pendant une
heure comment allez-vous jan masaryk
très très bien alors vous êtes pressenti
pour être ministre des finances on peut
aimer votre rigueur budgétaire mais
surtout sportive ça vous va comme
camille ça fait partie de mon autre
corde qui mon métier comme la finance
donc vous avez un métier j'ai un métier
ouais je ne suis pas rémunéré par
téléphone 18 bon le message est passé en
championnat
alors ça c'est pour ça qu'on n'est pas
tout le temps était au rendez
vous êtes excusés alors on continue
notre tour de table à gauche musique il
est journaliste chez tv 78 est une
véritable encyclopédie sur le sport
local il va tout donner avant de partir
en vacances notre italienne lovers le
seul l'unique et grégory canal est avec
nous pendant une heure comment elle
évolue l'orégon saint michel bonjour
yann m'a écouté très bien bien installés
pour parler de sport avec le retour de
ian en plus en pleine avant vous on vous
imagine ministre de la culture avec vos
envolées littéraires à l'image d'une
parade à la bouffonne votre éloquence
digne des plus grands artistes italiens
de la renaissance vous prenez bah écoute
et j'en suis très touché beaucoup de
beaucoup de missions une grosse un gros
rôle juste après la période qu'on vient
de traverser donc c'est beaucoup de
responsabilités oui mais vous mais merci
en tout cas pour ce ministère ça me
touche alors on continue de l'autre côté
musique7 heavy noah est venu tout droit
de la cité royale de versailles il est
toujours très élégant il est toujours en
pleine forme il a toujours la banane
quand il parle de sport dans cette
émission le surnomme le gladiateur
pierre chevalier du rugby-club de
versailles est avec vous pendant une
heure bonjour bien ça lui michael salut
tout salut les copains et c'est bien
alors vous avoue m ministre de
l'environnement alors vous êtes très
golf vous aimez le vert rouler en
voiture électrique de golf pour aller de
trou en trou par exemple alors vous
inviter une petite commune aussi dans
les yvelines est ce que ça vous voir ça
me va très bien d'autres aux trousses et
absolument très poétique chose de
magnifique magnifique et de toute façon
mieux en elle et je suis je suis
toujours durable quoi qu'il en soit
toujours dur à enfin voici notre dernier
chroniqueur une légende sur ce plateau
musique son charisme n'est plus à
démontrer ses coups de gueule ne peuvent
être imité son franc-parler devenu
mythique c'est toujours un immense
honneur de le recevoir coach jean vice
ex-entraîneur de plaisir est avec nous
beauchamp miguel bose soirée pop mesure
à tout le monde mais quand allez-vous
gens toujours plein de formes alors vous
on vous a attribué la place beauvau le
ministère de l'intérieur on connaît vos
stratégies défensives aussi solide qu'un
barrage de crs c'est bien ça vous aimez
faire respecter la loi vous aimez
soutenir les arbitres de telles ententes
et puis voilà c'est tout à fait moi ah
non non mais tramon mètres à l'intérieur
bon ok ça vous va c'est qu'il
me laisse pantois
bon en tout cas tout est attribuée on va
passer au programme de l'émission mais
avant par les eaux du programme en
parler tennis l'yvelinois arthur et 9,9
n'a pas participé au tournoi atp 500 de
barcelone le joueur originaire de saint
jean dans l'est a déclaré forfait en
raison d'une blessure au poignet droit
nouveau coup dur pour le 57e joueur
mondial à l'open d'australie en début de
saison il avait déjà dû déclarer forfait
en raison d'une douleur au même endroit
il espère maintenant pouvoir récupérer
en vue de roland garros le tournoi
débutera fin mai du côté de la porte
d'auteuil la question sur cette
thématique est ce qu'il faut commencer à
s'inquiéter pour la santé physique
d'arthur reinhardt neige non pour vous
pierre vous avez été le premier à
dégainer
vous êtes partagés ont fait un petit
duel entre vous grégory et pierre
grégory vous commencez moi je suis
partagé parce que je dirais déjà que non
on l'a dit souvent dans cette émission
ce qui arrive à arthur inerte neige
c'est que du bonus maintenant il est là
il est les proches de ce top 50 mondial
il a réalisé de belles performances de
match en tournoi du grand chelem qui là
qu'il a remporté moi je vais être un peu
plus on va dire partager parce que
j'attends de voir ce qui va se passer
sur la suite de la saison là il a
récidivé parce qu'il s'était blessé lors
de l'australian open il avait dû
déclarer forfait au bout du deuxième
tour et ne ne pas pouvoir jouer ce
match-là il déclare de nouveau forfait
juste avant avant cette avant ce tournoi
à barcelone donc j'ai envie de dire il
faut être prudent il faut être prudent
sur aussi les temps de récupération
là si je prends c'est ton en 2022 juste
après l'australian open il a joué à doha
il a joué à indian wells il a joué à
miami à monte carlo peut-être qu'il n'a
pas totalement récupéré donc moi le
conseil que je pourrais donner après
j'ai pas des conseils à donner mais
c'est peut-être d'avoir un temps de
récupération un peu plus long parce que
si la blessure se représente à nouveau
il peut peut-être adil et aussi ses
chances de continuer sa carrière si si
cette blessure se représente à nouveau
donc faire une pause faire une pause et
repose et voilà prendre un temps de
récupération nécessaire peut être qu'il
a trop joué en ce début d'année 2022
pierre chevallier a de solides arguments
tout à fait tout à fait petit
confirmation 27 ans
26 ans oui 26 donc l'avenir devant lui
même s'il est arrivé sur le tard sur le
sur le tennis professionnel et on le
sait après ses années aux états unis et
puis son arrivée en france c'est un
c'est un athlète qui je pense est quand
on est encore dans la fleur de l'âge
donc pas d'inquiétude sur son sur son
niveau physique le seul peut-être le
seul bémol ça de dire que c'est que
c'est une blessure ciblées sur un
poignet on va pas dire qu'est ce que
c'est que ce n'est pas utile au tennis a
le poignet surtout s'il est surtout si
des droitiers donc mais il est dont il
est dans la force de l'âge il est
surtout il est on là on l'a souvent dit
ici extrêmement prometteur et plein
d'enthousiasmé je pense que sur la
partie sur la partie physique ça peut
être compenser largement par tout ce qui
est tout ce qui est mental et cet
enthousiasme est qu'il montre depuis le
départ sur sur les tournois individuels
l'étoile des majeurs et puis les et puis
la coupe davis donc pour l'instant je
dirais il n'y a pas péril en la demeure
il est il et il est malgré tout en
pleine bourre c'est là que j'ai dit mon
fils l'a rappelé il est il et il est
justement dans cette danse est dans
cette boulimie tournoi c'est vrai que ça
peut ça peut justement ça peut un peu
émoussés les physiques mais en tout cas
jusqu'à maintenant il a montré que
malgré cette blessure qui ce qui ce qui
se révèle au monde de l'open d'australie
il a quand même eu des résultats et des
matches des matches gagnés et des bonnes
prestations juste avant donc je dirais
de toute façon en pur optimiste on peut
le croire prêts pour garros notamment
parce que c'est là où on attendra et que
sur 1 sur une
peut-être une blessure de fatigue de
ceux de genre d'usure à 26 ans ça se
remet vite viens déjà il y alors vous
vous étiez aussi partagez j'étais
partagé parce que en effet qui vous a
convaincu les écoule
adversaires les deux personnes non parce
que moi je fais le tu trouve qu'on n'a
pas assez d'informations sur la blessure
d sur au poignet ok
et est-ce que c'est pas simplement je
pensais faire barcelone est en effet
j'ai pas encore suffisamment récupéré où
j'ai enchaîné quelques tournois et du
coup je dis que je suis blessé photo qui
circule où on voit avec un voile à un
poignet bandé
les yeux et j'ai oublié qu'il était sûr
mais simplement je préfère éviter
d'aller à barcelone pour pouvoir me
faire une semaine de récup une semaine
de physique supplémentaire qui va me
permettre de pouvoir être mieux à roland
garros donc parce que comme vous le
dites on va tous nous attendre à roland
garros on souhaite que enfin tout ce qui
nous nous les supporters et supporters
biennois voilà les gros ça sera localisé
les cacher mais des voix et deux
d'argent comme tous les français sont
attendus à roland garros on espère qu'il
va passer qui sera la deuxième semaine
tout simplement donc bah oui il faut
passer quelques quelquefois inégalités
match et passer quelques toits donc
voilà est-ce que c'est une phase de
récupération je trouve je pense qu'on a
tous voila je suis dis parce que j'ai
pas assez d'informations sur la blessure
on connaît pas la durée
d'indisponibilité n'a pas communiqué sur
la fatigue et donc cesser de la seule
raison pour que je suis je suis je suis
mitigé parce que après oui en effet
l'avenir nous dira et on ne lui souhaite
que du monde je dirais que il peut le
voir un bon ami à moi qui ai
cherché un
clic de trappes voilà on va rester dans
le et qui pourra peut-être lui donner
des retraites c'est pas trés le
genre qu'est ce qu'ils en pensaient
bêtise en maîtrisant
yens lundi après il ya des jours comme
il était derrière très tôt à cause de
blessures par exemple oui mais des
grosses blessures oui les grosses
blessures
là on ne sait pas parce qu'on n'est pas
à vendre le dans le vif on ne sait pas
si c'est effectivement une blessure pour
ce s'économiser et pouvoir être
performant et sur roland garros
ou si c'est vraiment une blessure
je pense qu'il ya une réelle gestion
mais il a 26 ans 26 ans il faut qu'il y
fait il faut que l'ia qui la chaîne
si la chine peut maintenant si commence
à calculer avec six ans qu'elle ça va
être à 30 34 35 ans donc donc il a l'âge
pour lui il a besoin de forces il a
plein progression au niveau du tennis
c'est sûr que les blessures font partie
du sportif de haut niveau et c'en est
une elle est au bon endroit le pro bowl
en droit on peut pas le savoir on ne
sait pas encore une fois ci c'est
vraiment une blessure ou si c'est pour
s'économiser pour l'année roth mais là
on est tous d'accord sur le plateau pour
dire que c'est roland garros qu'on
l'attend et c'est ça donc est ce que
c'est un bien pour un mal ou un mal pour
un bien la réponse ce sera à roland
garros et la terre battue est une
surface quand même qui est assez
traumatisante ans quand même pour les
joueurs en général - gamme oui mais
qu'il manque quand même beaucoup de ceux
de -8 même moins que l'oreille des
matchs souvent plus longs oui mais oui
mais c'est moins que le quick au niveau
physique le quick willow quick c'est à
dire
le droit
pour les spécialistes ce spécialiste
des cinq sets et du day break entre en
ligne de compte dès cette année pour le
5ème set oui normalement oui
ça sera mon traumatique ce moment là
notamment la non surtaxé particularité
française mais n'apprend pas aussi voilà
d'une partie du corps anodine pour un
tennisman le poignet surtout qu'on sait
que lui sa grosse force et le coup droit
c'est le service alors tu as in darkness
moi j'ai insisté il faut pas non mais
faut non mais faut être prudent faut
être prudent il n'est pas pressé
d'autant qu'il a fait une énorme année
on peut comprendre qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient prêts s'il a fait une énorme
manne et 2021 première grosse année sur
le circuit en 1 re année ils rêvent
d'intégrer le top 30 il nous l'avait
confié à deux niveaux il n'avait pas
voulu fixer d'objectifs dont on peut
comprendre qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
pressés mais attention à pas griller les
étapes sur sur la récupération c'est
chaud comme le tennis lui qu'il se
blesse au lobe de l'oreille oui
exception c'est vachement bon en mettant
à sa merci pour votre analyse est
l'égérie alors seulement maintenant face
des blessures au poignet oui il fait le
bon faire le
jeu mais sur le but est au révélateur
pour passer au programme de l'émission
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de la
retraite sportive d'aurélien collin dans
le football chinois et est une légende
de la mls le championnat américain nous
parlons également de rugby plaisir
termine finalement 7e de fédérale 2 est
ce que c'est une déception pour le club
mais avant de parler de ces thèmes on va
parler du psg
[Musique]
on va donc parler du psg le club
implanté dans les yvelines à saint
germain en laye a été sacrée pour la 10e
fois de son histoire champion de france
après son match nul contre lens ce
samedi 23 avril c'est seulement la
deuxième équipe française à avoir
atteint ce chiffre après à saint-etienne
mais ce titre a une saveur amère surtout
à cause des supporters ces derniers
n'ont pas voulu fêter le titre à
l'intérieur du stade mais à l'extérieur
les chèques en ligue des champions
contre le real madrid n'est toujours pas
digéré la question sur cette thématique
ce 10e titre at il une triste saveurs
oui ou non vous voter oui pour ouvrir ce
que vous êtes unanime autour de ce
plateau alors contradictoires bon on va
vous donner la paroles gregory et après
on laissera les autres déroulée non mais
c'est sûr je vais les laisser développer
sur le titre sans saveur on sait que et
on en a parlé la dernière fois quand les
qataris sont arrivés à la tête du psg
c'est clairement pas pour emporter
énormément de ligue 1 on les attendait
sur la ligue des champions pour
l'instant ce constat et c'est un échec
il ya une finale sur ce final eight un
peu spécifique en 2020 mais la ligue des
champions n'est pas arrivé maintenant
dans l'histoire du football français
même si c'est à coup de millions à coups
de milliards on parle d'un milliards
déboursés depuis l'arrivée des qataris
et bien force est de constater que le
psg rentre dans l'histoire du football
français puisqu'il ya ce 10e titre de
champion de france qui est acquis et psg
égale un club historique comme
saint-etienne donc ils rentrent de cette
manière même si c'est à coup de
milliards dans l'histoire du football
français maintenant oui je vais
rejoindre les camarades et les laisser
développer là dessus sur le fait que le
titre est sans saveur parce que on
n'attend plus que la ligue des on
n'attend plus que le championnat et en
ligue des champions pour pour le paris
saint germain pierre chevallier qu'est
ce que vous en pensez c'est quand même
voilà le un nouveau type pour les
cathares y avait seulement deux titres
de champion de france avant l'arrivée
des qataris est et en 1986 et 1994 oui
là on pose la question sur la sur la
saveur et sur l'engouement des de
l'engouement des supporters est
globalement du football français voyait
deux choses qui marquent la première
c'est qu'on est dans une on est on est
définitivement est bel et bien dans la
nation poulidor tient en gros on est on
est on est sûr là on est sur le second
magnifique donc là on parle d'un titre
mais c'est en gros veut toujours plus
toujours plus et on veut on veut
vraiment on veut vraiment de du
clinquant on veut on veut on veut des
titres à n'en plus finir c'est vrai que
la maintenance et la ligue des champions
que que l'on vise depuis depuis dix ans
avec le psg je fais pas de politique
mais je dis qu en gros les résultats de
l'élection de la semaine dernier en gros
ne reconnaissent pas finalement gagnant
parce que c'est parce que c'est comme ça
on est on est des râleurs on est déroulé
des gaulois et sur la deuxième chose
c'est que on est on est dans une
position déçu par rapport à tout
l'investissement qui a été fait
justement sur le sur le football
français à travers le qatar et le psg où
on rate la marche à chaque fois vous
l'avez rappelé on a on l on a une finale
en 2020 qui était une finale très
particulière dans des conditions de que
vides on la perd contre le bayern et
puis et puis on arrive on arrive pas on
n'arrive pas à trouver la symbiose et à
trouver justement 7,7 cette osmose avec
avec un parterre de stars on va en
chercher certaines qui ne finissent par
jouer que qu'à la fin comme ramos
qui ne finissent par brillé que par
intermittence quand les mains même pas
né ici parce que il aida hill house roh
grosso modo raté sa saison et on a une
pépite qu'on essaye de garder coûte que
coûte com com qui les amap et oui je
sais c'est une un titre sans saveur
parce que on a on a quand même un parc
des princes qui est qui est qui et qui
composait de deux fidèles parmi les
fidèles de le cop auteuil kop boulogne
et c'est
là le silence assourdissant qui a eu qu
à lui dimanche dernier
il faudra pas retrouver les supporters
sont partis un quart d'heure vingt
minutes avant la fin du match et ils ont
fêté le titre à l'exiger cette agence
qui prévoyait justement prévoyez ce type
de manifestation et de d'exprimer leur
mécontentement malgré tout et c'est un
partout c'est un match nul contre une
bonne équipe de guides ce que lance le
rc lens est une bonne équipe devient et
malgré tout s'est passé c'est d'une
tristesse absolue parce que c'est
c'est quand même un dixième titre
grégory l'a rappelé et c'est pas rien
quand même c'est pas rien dans
l'histoire du volley seront faits dans
la ligne 1 même si la ligue 1 n'est pas
au niveau peut-être des championnats des
championnats européens mais mais un
titre comme celui là qui est terne qui
est silencieux ne dit pas ne dit pas
grand chose et ne dit pas de bonnes
choses sur le l'état du championnat
français il a dit je vous trouve très
dur avec naïma quand même il a organisé
la soirée pour fêter le titre et vous
l'avez critiquer
vous seront très durs avec lui pierre
chevallier jan qu'est ce que vous en
pensez titre sans savoir aussi pour vous
ouais ouais ouais carrément
depuis qu'elle vit le qatar est arrivé
c'est la seule fois que le psg ne gagne
aucun titre
depuis plusieurs années on est habitués
à les voir faire un doublé
coupe-championnat avoir un triplé avec
aprilia une coupe de la ligue au 6
mai mais voilà je vais lui qu'est cet
échec en plus sur ses dix saisons la
première année montpellier il ya eu
aussi l'année de monaco et l'année
dernière lille
[Musique]
ça heureusement que qui n'ont pas non
plus une super cette suprématie parce
que à la lyonnaise qui avait enchaîné
sept ou huit cet outil d'affilée voilà
donc donc voilà pour moi il est sans
saveur parce que déjà on sait qu'ils
sont champions depuis mi novembre parce
que là avance qu'ils ont championnat
elle était quand même déjà très
conséquente à la fin de la à la fin des
matches aller même avant la fin des
matches aller donc on savait qu'ils
seraient champions et en plus bien voilà
cette grosse déconvenue face face au
real ou encore en 1 l'espace d'un quart
d'heure ça le match le match tourne donc
donc voilà c'est clair que le titre
n'est pas suffisant pour pour satisfaire
les supporters et je le comprends
complètement et là où je rejoins
on est on est en pierre on devient mon
collègue voilà on devient
très comment tu as dit on veut
l'excellence tvo l'objet d'exigences
gens deviennent exigeants tout
simplement l'équipe de france veut dire
on a aussi de l'autre côté c'est à dire
une équipe qui est capable de devenir
championne d'europe de gagner des titres
de championne de la coupe du monde on va
avoir une équipe qui est peut-être
l'équipe de france la plus forte que
l'on peut avoir depuis depuis des années
c'est pas le débat mais juste voilà on
devient on est devenus exigeants et
c'est vrai que on espère que parce que
faut pas oublier c'est que ça fait
depuis
85 93 des français l'a remporté c'est
quelqu'un du nickel le lapsus est donc
que c'est quand même très très long en
termes de reconnaissance au niveau
européen et en plus à côté de ça il n'y
a rien dans mes dans les dents les
autres dans les autres coupes annexes
c'est à dire que oui on a fait des
finales avec monaco on a fait des mais
voilà il n'y a pas de club qui arriva à
briller au niveau européen et c'est vrai
que je pense que c'est ça qui frustre
encore beaucoup gens qu'est ce qu'ils en
pensaient ce que les supporters aussi
sont pas déçus par le recrutement
annoncé un recrutement xxl messi donne à
roma me parlez pas le recrutement mois
leur côté mais le juge a exprimé sur ce
plateau à plusieurs reprises et moi je
veux faire pour une fois je veux faire
l'avocat du diable du psg il ya deux
choses moi qui me choque c'est que les
gens pensent que parce que le qatar hier
avec les millions derrière les millions
et l'evora les milliards puisque greg a
dit que ça a coûté 1 milliard donc on
est obligé
d'avoir d'avoir la coupe d'europe des
clubs champions et mais c'est quand même
sportivement on est quand même il l'a
dit greg l'a dit le dise le titre gm de
nos france c'est pas c'est pas n'importe
quoi quand même c'est quand même
sportivement une rue une performance
qu'il faut souligner et qu'on oublie de
souligner sportivement parce que ya des
millions n'est rien on est obligé de
faire plus et c'est là ça me gêne parce
qu'on se dit on est en train de dire que
parce qu'il ya de l'argent il doit y
avoir du résultat non c'est pas ça le
sport et la l'argent efface la
performance sportive pour moi c'est à
dire que c'est quand même le dixième
titre mais ça passe ça passe quasiment
inaperçue dans les médias etc qui me la
deuxième chose que je voulais signaler
c'est que ce qui me déplaît encore plus
c'est que ça passe inaperçu auprès des
supporters pour moi un vrai supporters
et pour moi alors le scellant ce qui est
pour moi je veux ce que j'ai ça en tête
mes vrais supporters y les supporters
dans le bien comme dans le mal donc là
c'est même pas du mal c'est du bien sûr
le championnat de france ils sont chefs
de nos phases pour la dixième fois et
pays boudent ils faussent à l'extérieur
mais je leur mettrais des gars de tarte
à la gueule moi c'est tout comme faut
arrêter un petit peu sportivement c'est
un dixième titre châble france des soi
disants supporters du psg mais tu dois
mais tu dois le célébrer c'était le
titre il ya des clubs français qui n'ont
jamais été championne phrase donc
c'était inadmissible pour moi de d'avoir
fait cette espèce de gamineries d'aller
fêter ça à l'extérieur mais moi je en
forêt il était enfant gâté peut-être
nous sommes à we have a gâté enfin gâtés
tout à fait enfant gâté et là là là moi
ce moment j'aurais rajouté des ddd
doc le garde des sceaux j'en ai 2 td
sont les plus voilà une saison sans
saveur c'est vraiment la saison du
désamour entre les supporters du psg et
leur club il ya des épisodes forcément
ian disait le psg est champion depuis de
nombreux mois on le sait
mathématiquement c'était pas le cas mais
on savait dans les faits avec cette
grosse avance en championnat que ça
allait être le cas donc il devait se
concentrer sur la ligue des champions il
ya eu un échec donc je pense que voilà
ça vient largement de la déception des
supporters il y avait eu des gros
incident faut pas oublier que messi
lionel messi alors il n'a pas fait une
énorme saison au paris saint germain il
était très fantomatique ne nous le
cachons pas que notre but en ligue 1
mais siffler mais si il ya eu un il ya
eu une polémique mondiale un beaucoup de
personnes personnalités du football se
sont saisis du sujet ça n'a pas été
compris même s'il n'a pas eu le
rendement escompté de la part des
supporters du paris saint germain en
laye marche peut comprendre un peu plus
même si voilà moi je suis jamais contre
siffler un joueur c'est compliqué c'est
jamais facile neymar ya un peu plus de
raison il ya plus d'années il ya plus de
passif pour neymar mais messi la légende
qu'il est il ya une cassure je pense à
ce moment là entre le psg et son équipe
il y avait une tache indélébile de narva
c'est un peu plus contrastée de la roma
bon je suis je suis supporter
non lahesalu psg qui paye de sa mauvaise
gestion on la honte j'en ai parlé à la
dernière fois la gestion des gardiens ce
n'est pas la première année qu'il ya
deux gardiens qui peuvent être numéro 1
au psg et cette gestion d'avoir un
double numéro un n'a pas aidé l'équipe
parce que l'équipe ne joue pas avec le
même gardien n'y a pas la même confiance
et même pour le gardien lui même le fait
de ne pas accumuler les matches hyper
des réflexes qui perd de la confiance et
donc ça c'est aussi c'est aussi un échec
sur le recrutement très rapidement
au final le recrutement le plus on va
dire logique il yaa qui me donna roma il
aurait dû résoudre le cas navas s'il
voulait le recruter mais les autres
finalement c'est à coups de à coups de
millions c'est du un coup marketing on
l'a dit la principale réussite du psg
sur ses dix ans et le marketing ils ont
gagné ils sont passés à 10 j'ai pu le
chiffre en tête steve millions 2
milliards en tout cas le psg la marque
psg vaut 2 milliards de milliards 5 de
plus d'après forbes donc ils ont
vraiment réussi leur coup marketing on
les attendait aussi sur le côté sportif
et c'est plus des recrutements marketing
à mon sens le l'été dernier tronçon va
passer aux autres thématiques y en a
beaucoup je rejoint greg saisi c'est sûr
vous fait l'état d'esprit des supporters
par rapport aux recrues de 2000
2021-2022 un ramos on se trouve juste
parce que c'est un problème je pense à
problèmes de prise de renseignements
physique quand il n'est pas au niveau à
l'été 2000 21 et il l'a jamais été mais
alors elle m'a de ne voulais pas le
projet n'en pense aussi à physique reste
il ya sûrement une raison qui essayait
vraiment survolé la zone on l'a pris on
l'a vendu des maillots très bien 2 mais
cissé s'est pas exactement la même chose
que les marées je suis d'accord les
grecs mais cissé c'est plutôt une fin de
carrière mais ça reste messier et neymar
enfin là pour le coup c'est un problème
d'état d'esprit et d'état d'esprit sur
et en dehors du terrain est donc là
c'est c'est je pense que c'est un
melting-pot de toutes celles de toutes
ses sensations dans l'est dans le coeur
et dans le dans l'esprit des supporters
parisiens et qui donne cette c'est
effectivement je suis d'accord avec jean
aussi 7,7 ce décalage totalisé 7 cette
ineptie de ne pas fêter un titre de
champion de france 10e qu'ils soient
historiquement là il ya quand même il ya
un vrai problème de fond rapidement les
règles parce que je suis je voulais vous
expliquerai jugé frais pour cent par
rapport à mai si je suis d'accord là le
duo messi mba pays il a quand même très
bien marché voilà ça grimm bien pris ça
a mis du temps mais ça a marché juste
faut pas oublier moi je pense que les
supporters parisiens ils ont fêté
au mois de l'été dernier en fait le
titre al canton ici est arrivé en tête
voire messi est arrivé ils ont fait plus
la fête que que maintenant et donc du
coup ça me fait penser à des équipes qui
gagnent une demi-finale en disant super
on est en finale et la finale il passe
complètement à côté parce que justement
ils ont fait la fête ils ont fait la
fête et est donc mal et c'est un peu
jeune et très tôt dans la saison
finalement pays se sont vus très très
beau ils se sont vus très très beaux ils
sont des cantons va et quand on se voit
très très beau bas on tombe très très
bas donc voilà c'est et la grosse
désillusion est arrivé très tôt dans la
saison donc avec un titre qui était
gagné très tôt aussi ça donne ça donne
ce résultat là mais je suis complètement
d'accord avec jean quand on est
supporters on est supporters dans la
difficulté et on se souviendra du
passage de marseille en ligue 2 où le
vélodrome était plein
c'est d'une faisait les records de
faisait des records de 20 le mot de la
fin du coup sur cette thématique
j'ai lu thématique
parisienne à votre des marseillais on va
continuer à parler football dans votre
envolé à grégory le moment fort de cette
émission alors de quoi allez vous nous
parlez aujourd'hui le choix de carrière
qui peuvent se présenter au cours d'une
vie c'est vrai pour le sport c'est aussi
vrai pour le monde professionnel en
général parfois la voie de la réussite
peut être bouché en france et il vaut
mieux voguer vers d'autres horizons
partir à l'étranger par exemple pour
trouver son bonheur la fuite des talents
ce n'est jamais bon pour un pays
néanmoins cela peut s'avérer bénéfique
pour le talon en question le premier
exemple qui me vient en tête moelle
amoureux de football c'est antoine
griezmann jamais vraiment considéré par
la formation française trop petit trop
long trop loin des standards de la fff
dans les années 2000 misant davantage
sur les gros gabarits que sur la
technicité
le chemin vers la gloire grise où la
trouver du côté de l'espagne la real
sociedad lui a permis de grandir
sereinement pour devenir un top joueur
mondial et regarder les bleus on nous
finalement large en profiter ces
dernières années un yvelinois lui aussi
a dû se résoudre à quitter la france
pour poursuivre sa carrière aurait bien
un colin vient de tirer sa révérence à
36 ans son nom parle sans doute à peu de
personnes en france c'est tout autre
chose en revanche de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique où le défenseur a porté
haut les couleurs de son département
avec un maillot floqué du numéro 78 en
2020 il a même été sélectionné parmi les
137 finalistes des meilleurs joueurs de
l'histoire de la mls la major league
soccer passé par les jeunes de sedan et
damien aurélien ne parvient pas à percer
dans l'hexagone après avoir sillonné
l'europe en espagne écosse grèce au pays
de galles et au portugal c'est en 2011
que le français décide de s'envoler pour
les états unis il a alors 25 ans chacun
a son histoire mais c'est quelqu'un
travaille on peut tout arriver et la
france est un beau pays mais c'est un
moment c'est fermé comme moi c'était
fermé je suis parti parce que j'ai
beaucoup d'amis qui sont restés et qui
était en d2 dea et après ils sont restés
ils ont fait des deux national ou même
cfa même si si la france est fermé il
faut partir du massage quand je
conseille à tous parce que faut partir
de notre confort zone et il ya des
choses très très joli et d expérience
énorme à vivre en dehors de la france
donc c'est juste de conseil que jordan
et qu'elles vont choix aurélien collin a
va vivre un véritable rêve américain
l'yvelinois remporte le championnat
américain en 2013 avec kansas city une
première pour le club
le défenseur sera même désigné mvp de la
finale contre le real salt lake reçu à
la maison blanche et chambrer par barack
obama himself le président américain lui
envient ans son style vestimentaire
qu'elle classe j'ai envie de vous dire
alors ça ne s'arrête pas là aurélien
collin jouera également à orlando aux
new york red bull est aussi à
philadelphie et côtoiera quelques grands
noms du football qui était plutôt en fin
de carrière thierry henry ou encore kaka
l'yvelinois le disait lui même dans une
interview à ouest-france en 2021 il
était fait pour jouer et vivre aux états
unis je le cite aux états unis peu
importe ton parcours ton passé on te
regarde et si tu fait le taff tu réussis
en france à amiens alors que j'avais je
devais avoir dix huit ans j'étais
stagiaire pro le directeur sportif
m'avait puni parce que je venais de
faire percer les oreilles ici ça
n'arriverait jamais bref tout ça pour
dire une chose il vaut mieux parfois
partir pour mieux réussir quitte à
partir de son pays pour revenir un jour
plus épanoui je vous parlais de
griezmann au début de cette chronique
mais aurélien collin aussi est de retour
en europe pour se former aujourd'hui au
poste d'entraîneur et de managers entre
la france l'angleterre et l'espagne qui
c'est le rendez vous a été manquée pour
le joueur aurélien collin en france
peut-être qu'il sera réussie pour
l'entraîneur votre avis sur cette
envolée yann qu'est ce que vous en
pensez je suis complètement d'accord
avec ce qu'aurélien a dit avec ce que
grégory a dit aussi et dans le cyclisme
on a un bel exemple avec un petit garçon
qui s'appelle jules à philippe qui était
dans une équipe de quittant une équipe
amateur
ça va on vous allez entendre parler
bientôt il était dans une équipe armée
de terre dans les kebabs et dans les
cabines de mémoire et il a été dénichée
par le pas que des loups voilà une
équipe belge la quick step et il est
devenu ben vrai un très bon et ça me
fait vraiment passe pas vraiment pensé
oh comment s'appelle au parcours de de
griezmann voilà le métier de deux fois
champion du monde l'équipe de france en
bénéficient sauf que bas toute l'année
il joue dans une équipe dont une défaite
cours dans une équipe parce qu'on ne
joue pas au vélo il court dans une
équipe dans une équipe étrangère voilà
c'est et je pense que dans chaque sport
il doit y avoir des exemples comme cela
parce que il ya plein plein de 2,2
sportif qui passe entre les radars des
détections tout simplement genre qu'est
ce que vous en pensez donc voilà un
collant son parcours et le parcours
aussi de tous ces jeunes qui quittent la
france finalement pour réussir oui oui
oui mais c'est un bon parcours je dirais
que c'était mon parcours après bon
l'exemple que
que viens de citer jan il s'est appuyé
sur les semaines la sépaq espagne mais
il n'a pas réussi en france est bien
d'accord donc il est parti à l'étranger
parce qu'ils régissaient pas en france
donc
je dirais c'est bien c'est louable il a
fait sa carrière il a réussi à s'imposer
à l'étranger en l'occurrence aux états
unis et donc c'est très très bien c'est
très très bien après on voit quand même
que il a le mal du pays puisque ils
essaient de revenir
en europe pour une nouvelle carrière non
plus de joueurs mais le manager ou
d'entraîneurs oui enfin il veut se
former il vous sur vont repartir après
s'il a une opportunité en europe lui
dira pas non bien sûr oui bien sûr mais
ma fait bon pourquoi mais parfois tu
l'as fait ses réseaux
ses réseaux oui oui enfin bon ça je
pense qu'à moitié
si c'est vers 16 h en 10,8 voulais le
prendre comme general manager ni ne
serai pas là parce qu'on use états unis
au lieu du sport aux états unis en effet
on va faire deux le problème n'est pas
là mais bon certes mois pour moi c'est
bien c'est une belle carrière puisque il
est parti il a réussi à l'extérieur
personnellement je ne connais pas donc
c'est qu'il n'a pas marqué les mémoires
haut niveau au niveau france et
l'abattage pour lui c'est qu'il a réussi
est donc grand ne peut que que que dire
bravo à une réussite sportive juste
suppression ce que je voulais signer par
rapport à signaler par rapport à
griezmann c'est que le début de parcours
en fait et si mr parce que griezmann en
bus a carrément barré des portes en
france et peut-être qu'on n'aurait
jamais connu le griezmann champion du
monde s'il n'était pas parti en espagne
en france on lui a dit tu es trop petit
tu n'es pas dans les standards de
formation et là il est peut-être dans
limoilou est aussi oui les parties - là
il est pavé moi le vrai hélas zeender du
bâti de la real sociedad le prestigieux
d'europe mais c'est hélas là il est
parti et je sais même plus le club où il
était et sa city mais j'ai le kansas
city
ça fait pas rêver les footballeurs
excusez moi comme est bon mais il a mis
la ville sur l'axé du football est
d'accord on fait ça veut pas ça veut
voir arriver les footballeurs kansas
city je prenne ce plus au rodéo et
obtenir sur le cheval que que le
football beau pierre qu'est ce que vous
en pensez culture sport deux choses
premièrement c'est l'exposition du sport
en question et deuxièmement c'est la
culture du sport quand je dis la villa
je commençais par le deuxième la culture
du sport c'est que on a en a en france
encore maintenant même si c'est de moins
en moins le cas depuis 98 un déficit de
culture du sport et de l'importance du
sport dans le développement de la delà
de la personne et notamment dans les
programmes scolaires aussi donc aller
voir ce qui se passe dans les pays qui
eux mettre le sport à bonne place c'est
déjà une très bonne chose je prendrai
les choses je connais un parallèle qui
me tient à coeur c'est celui du golfe
évidemment avec tous les meilleurs
joueurs français qui en manque d'une
exposition au niveau français au niveau
européen vont se frotter aux meilleurs
niveaux qui soit c'est à dire sur le
circuit américain tous ceux qui ont
tenté 7,7 pas cela comme antoine rosters
par exemple ou comme des jeunes filles
comme céline boutier comme pauline
pauline roussin bouchard désormais
et doux et bien d'autres bien d'autres
amérique et bien d'autres américains je
lis bien d'autres français ils sont
revenus avec une culture complémentaires
et avec justement une peut-être un
meilleur niveau et une soif de gagner un
petit peu un petit peu différent
tennis exactement pareil et il est venu
sur le tard parce qu'il a été parce
qu'il a été accueilli au fait il a été
accueilli aux états unis comme ça donc
c'est mon premier point c'est là aussi
l'exposition du sport en question là si
on prend l'exemple du football pour
colin c'est c il a il a effectivement il
est passé sous les radars il n'a pas eu
sa chance forcément en france est ce que
c'est un bon film un mauvais signe qu'il
les eut aux états unis peu importe il
l'a eu il a brillé dans un championnat
qui est certes moins reluisant que la
liga que la première ligne que la ligue
1 où le
ou le championnat espagnol et peu
importe au final il
il acquiert un niveau il acquiert il à
dire finalement aussi des lettres de
noblesse qui ne lui était pas donné en
france est ce que est ce que maintenant
il faut il faut considérer que c'est que
c'est une mauvaise chose pour le
football français mais c'est en tout cas
si tu es ici d'une question d'exposition
de culture et tu lui a permis de
rebondir genre vous voulez réagir
rapidement parce qu'après on va passer
aux meilleurs souvenirs justement de
collants d'oran dans cet e mail est
d'accord non je veux juste réagir ce que
disait pierre c'est que là quand il a
cité l'exemple des golfeurs ils sont
partis aux états unis pour devenir
meilleurs et revenir à l'étape du fort
là c'est pas le cas pour moi c'est pas
le cas c'est qui
sportivement il était barré en france et
il est parti là-bas pour briller pour
mieux réussir donc c'est pas tout à fait
la même
le le même cas de figure sportif mais
que ce garçon avait peut-être sa place
en équipe de france
soir a dit que jamais de lui parler par
titre c'est tout par titre
déjà que leur place avec le fatah il ya
c'est catherine et l'a13 à la nouvelle
lui jamais ne lui parle de son nom
quand
giroud c'est giroud qui est parti dans
ces pages il si c'est géraud qu'est
partie la mesure où les parties non non
je m'étais gdaxi gignac quand gignac et
cissé qui a séparé il est aimé j'ai
claqué des coups alors pouvant ring
mexique ont participé les parties au
mexique à partir du moment où il est
parti jobbik si je vais jouer ce soir
non c'est parce que je veux dire je veux
juste dire il est il a disparu des
radars de l'équipe de france ils étaient
trop limités alors que l'âge alors qu'un
giroud qui n'a pas tu ne jouais pas mais
durant deux heures- tu parles de joueurs
qui étaient connus mais ça n'a rien à
voir je te veux juste que botul mais non
tu dis qui part qui parle ou ajustements
et tu le connais c'est lui qui le
connaissent et le joueur de foot tu le
connais c'est viscéral c'est pas le
débat l'embrouillé non mais j'ai plus de
cloche sur ce plateau mais j'accepte la
crèche décidé voilà qu aujourd hui je ne
pourrais pas vous réconcilier sur cette
thématique mais on va écouter pour
calmer un peu les esprits les meilleurs
souvenirs d'oreille au colloque comme
toujours ma finale en 2013 on a gagné on
a été champions et a été le haut ne
le pic de ma carrière en 2013 mais on a
gagné on a été champion des états unis
et de donner ça une équipe comme kansas
city qui était à l'époque une petite
équipe n'a vraiment changé la perception
des gens sur le kansas bon apparemment
ça a calmé tout le monde du coup on va
envoyer le deuxième souvenir devrait
dire que l'un c'est un souvenir par
rapport à obama y revient juste après
aux etats unis toutes les équipes
championnes vont à la maison blanche n'a
eu là le privilège de rencontrer obama
et ils voient la machine petit une
petite vanne après ça monte déjà fin
2014 et ça restera aussi dans ma mémoire
c'était quoi la petite veine mais
c'était par rapport à la manière avec
laquelle j'étais habillé à l'époque
j'avais des magasins de vêtements et
j'avais une foulards et des boucles
d'oreilles il a dit aux accueils ils
vont me ressemblent quand il sortira de
l'office de la maison blanche bonjour il
a il a quand même des beaux souvenirs
quand même de cette aventure américaine
avait heureusement ça n'a absolument
rien à mon avis est le makhila il a bien
mené sa carrière et que c'est très bien
pour lui voilà c'est tout mais pas au
point de l'emmener en équipe de france
et d'après ce qu'on a compris mais je
connaissais donc forcément il était pas
pendre guy lefranc puisque c'est qu'un
garçon qui dans le giron footballistique
il n'était pas connu bon on va passer
maintenant notre prochaine thématique
peut-être qui aura un débat un peu moins
enflammés mais tout de même quand même
on va parler rugby et plus précisément
de fédérale 2 plaisir n'a pas réussi à
terminer dans le top 6 du classement
synonyme de phases finales il échoue à
la septième place de la poule à
seulement quelques points de cette
dernière place qualificative c'était
pourtant l'objectif annoncé en début de
saison ou en tout cas un désir la
question sur cette thématique est ce que
c'est une vraie déception pour le club à
votre avis
vous êtes partagés
pas bon on va faire un tour de table va
faire un tour de table yann qu'est ce
que vous en pensez 7e 6e 10 s'est
qualifié ces thèmes sont pas que ça
tienne à combien à combien de points à
combien de temps exactement il fera six
points du rheu donc six points c'est
plus qu'un match avec bonus etc puisque
ses cinq points cinq points au rugby
donc c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup 6
points et surtout quand on se retrouve
dans le milieu du tableau
normalement là où il ya une densité
beaucoup plus important donc donc ils
sont bien oui ils sont à leur place je
pensais tout simplement parce que on a
des gens n'a pas du tout parlé pendant
toute l'année donc ça veut dire que
c'était peut-être aussi un
objectif qui était difficilement
atteignable je pense que s'ils avaient
été lésés qu'ils étaient censés rentrer
vous en fait toute l'année et bientôt
vers le bas du classement pendant une
partie de l'année ils sont remontés
petit à petit ils ont fait des beaux
résultats a été dans la course devait
voir ils ont je crois à accrocher les
leaders du classement ils ont accroché
quelques gros mais ça leur a pas permis
de se qualifie donc de constance parce
qu'un championnat ça ne se joue pas sur
quelle que ce ne soit pas sur un match
comme une coupe ou on les prend match
par match ça joue sur la sur la durée
donc simplement manque de constance et
ben c'est peut-être là dessus qu'il va
falloir travailler l'année prochaine
grégory en scène je donne la parole aux
spécialistes homme là qui sont en train
de réviser après
là où je suis pas forcément déçu c'est
sûr le fait aussi que c'est une deuxième
saison pour en fédérale 2 ce fait deux
ans qu'ils sont en fait bien quatre ans
là bas il ya des combats mon argument
qu'on vide c'est d'accord bon bah je
vais laisser la parole je vais réfléchir
un prochain mariage sur deux choses qui
m'ont fait finir par dire oui c'est
décevant premièrement si c'est la
quatrième voire cinquième saison en
fédérale 2 genre depuis longtemps que le
genre
d'excès
et deuxième seller ce que vous avez
rappelé indirectement michael c'est la
physionomie de la saison où ils ont
terminé très fort la première première
raison c'est ça fait déjà quatre saisons
qui sont en fédérale 2 en tant que
versailles est évidemment qui regardons
un petit peu un étage du sud vers la
fédérale 2 c'est quelque chose d'assez
inspirant et c'est à dire qu'en fait au
bout de quatre saisons on a un petit peu
on a un petit peu appréhender justement
le niveau et les exigences de la
fédérale 2 il ya un vrai gap entre la
fédérale 3 la fédérale 2 oloron on est
bien placé et plaisir et
maisons-laffitte et versailles pour le
pour le dire et justement c'est ça c'est
ça qui est qui est assez inspirant dans
le dans l'histoire de plaisir c'est que
au bout de quatre saisons ils ont réussi
à se maintenir déjà chaque année ça
c'est une gageur et et malgré les malgré
les quelques fortes oppositions parce
que quand tu l'aidés les équipes de
hautpoul change chaque année et donc son
sont aussi là pour le coup assez
challenge and john donc c'est c'est ce
qui me fait ce qui me fait dire que
c'est un petit peu décevant c'est que au
bout de la quatrième saison il aurait pu
il aurait pu justement choper un train
pour les y avait des phases finales
deuxième raison c'est cette fin de
saison où ils effectivement vous l'avez
rappelé il termine très très fort il
accroche des gros chez eux et à
l'extérieur donc ils ont ils ont dû
trouver l'alchimie justement est le
l'organisation sportive et puis le
mental le mental qui fait que l'on va on
va on va accrocher les scalps de deux
grosses équipes donc c'est là encore à
10 mètres du bol de sangria on
meurt à six points c'est là c'est là où
c'est c'est un petit peu de ce vent
quatre saisons après ils sont toujours
en fédérale 2 peut-être qu'on les
retrouvera je fais ce voeu pieux avec
avec versailles dont dans une poule
peut-être analogues mais en tout cas
c'est
décevant mais en tout cas louable c'est
prometteur en tout cas pour la saison
prochaine jean qu'est ce que vous en
pensez votre ancien club alors tout
simplement pour moi l'objectif du club
était la qualification d'accord
lorsqu'on sait que quand on prend un
objectif c'est rarement pour la tène
c'est pour au moins se rapprocher la
tène c'est vraiment la saison parfaite
on va dire l'objectif pour eux c'était
la qualification ce qui veut dire que
avec ses deux années qui viennent de
passer qu'ovide où ça a été complètement
tronquée cette saison était devant une
grosse surprise pour eux en fédérale 2
il s'avère que et vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure il était dans le ventre mou
quasiment une grande partie de la saison
et ensuite et pierre l'a dit il ont
accroché ils ont accroché des belles
équipes notamment notamment la grande
performance c'est nantes à la maison qui
était leader incontesté et incontestable
de cette poule oui c'est 100 points
c'était le monstre de la poule et ils
les ont battus 34 en tout 31 fait à un
plaisir est là et là c'est vrai que ben
ils se sont certainement et penser à
rêver de l'objectif et de la
qualification mais à mon avis
honnêtement ce n'était peut-être pas le
l'objectif annoncé mais comme je le dis
je le répète mais déjà finir pour moi 7e
juste au bord de la qualification c'est
pour moi une belle prestation sur un
retour après deux saisons de de données
en donner un donc c'est une belle
performance qui pour moi pour la saison
prochain va leur servir énormément et là
à mon avis ils ont quand même il aucun
réussi à acquérir une une belle
prestance à ce niveau là et là
maintenant pour moi plaisir l'année
prochaine sont à partie des belles
équipes de fédérale 2 sur qui il faudra
compter et non pas dans la deuxième
partie mais la première partie du
championnat prometteur donc tout à fait
bon ça fait plaisir en tout cas d'aller
le plus haut possible l'année prochaine
dans cette fédérale 2 on va passer
maintenant notre page débat parce qu'il
faut avancer dans cette émission
[Musique]
dans cette page débats on va parler box
livi noise maiva hamadouche n'arrêtera
finalement pas à sa carrière la boxeuse
avait pourtant annoncé cette décision
sur les réseaux sociaux après
l'annulation de son combat programmé à
dubaï en mai prochain face à la belge
delphine personnes la sportive de 32 ans
avait été écrit mercredi dernier
j'arrête ma carrière j'ai fait de belles
choses des propos supprimer quelques
instants plus tard joint par téléphone
son agent a bien confirmé que maiva
hamadouche allait continuer à boxer
malgré ce coup de sang sur les réseaux
sociaux la sportive entraînée par la
team farruggia il en cours avant les jo
de tokyo attend désormais un nouveau
challenge la question sur cette
thématique comprenez vous ce coup de
sang oui ou non
oui pour vous il ya louis pour vos
pierres oui pour grégory et non pour
vous un jour vous êtes seul contre tous
décidément aujourd'hui vous êtes vous
êtes énervé un nom je veux un arrêt non
pas du tout alors pourquoi alors
n'aurait simplement il vaut la
communication dit simplement au niveau
de jeudi n'ont simplement lieu de la
communication c'est à dire que ça fait
un petit peu désordre au niveau de la
communication d'une championne qui qui
annonce sa retraite et qui peut très
vite très rapidement dinan finalement je
continue donc c'est simplement pour ça
que je dis non parce que ben
allez je vais exiger ça fait pas très
sérieux quoi ça fait pas très sérieux
alors je sais pas si c'est elle qui a 4
x ray ou si c'est la communication elle
apparaît mais alors certainement sur un
moment de 2-2-2 de blues
elle a banalisé ça mais voilà c'est pour
ça que j'ai dit non parce que justement
sur un champion sur une championne en
l'occurrence pour moi mais ça fait pas
très sérieux juste préciser c'est
d'ailleurs ici le planer le doute c'est
que c'est pas un puits tout une
publication qui est resté dans le temps
c'est sur une story donc c'est à dire
c'est une publication qu'on publie et
qui reste sur 24 heures qui disparaît on
est assez abasourdi pour le dire quand
on a appris la nouvelle c'est un article
d'un média alors qu'il n'est pas
concurrent d'un média sportif dans le
paysage français qui annonçaient qu'ils
étaient sûrs à 100% de la retraite de
mme aïda ma douche qui revenait un peu
sur sa carrière on a été un peu
abasourdi au vu des derniers événements
et c'est vrai quand on a fait les
recherches on n'a pas trouvé la story en
question puisqu'elle avait disparu et
c'est après son agent qui vous a
confirmé au téléphone michael que
c'était un coup de sang moi je comprends
le coup de sang au vu du passé récent
après je vais pas revenir sur les coups
de com et une coupe comme ratée pour le
coup vous rejoins un petit peu gens sur
sur ça mais oui je comprends le coup de
sang au vu des du passé récent sur les
combats de maija hamadouche on sait
qu'elle était très déçu suite à ces jo
il ya eu une défaite dans des conditions
un peu litigieuse à l'avait remis en
question face à la finlandaise
l'arbitrage et avait valu d'ailleurs une
de mes dents volé sept cette saison et à
la berlue aussi juste après les jo elle
est revenue sur les combats
professionnels elle a perdu elle avait
une tentative d'unifier ses deux
ceintures mondiales ce qu'on rappelle a
quand même sept titres de championne du
monde dans sa carrière ce qui n'est ce
qui n'est pas rien elle avait tenté
d'unifier deux ceintures mondiales pour
être on va dire la la super championne
mondiale dans sa catégorie et une
défaite également aux points et la
meilleure c'est en novembre dernier
c'est sa face à l'américaine une
décision unanime des juges donc on peut
comprendre qu'ils aient une petite
amertume parce que elle a aujourd'hui 32
ans elle arrive plus tôt à halo reach sa
carrière le gros de sakae plutôt
derrière il lui reste encore quelques
années et je pense qu'il ya des
occasions des occasions manquées
justement qu'elle ne voulait pas manquer
là en l'occurrence ils viennent quand
même une forte exposition c'est un
combat qui était attendu face à alabel
je perds soon et c était aussi dans une
soirée où il y avait floyd mayweather
qui devait combat donc c'était une
soirée quand même avec une grosse
exposition donc je peux comprendre que
sur ses occasions qui finalement ne vont
pas se présenter elle peut être déçu
donc je comprends tout à fait ce coup de
sang oui en gros elle a appris la
nouvelle à la presse rapporte à bâle a
fait horie elle a effacé dix minutes 15
minutes après pierre chevalier je pense
ensuite c'est un tout
et un ensemble de frustration on en
parle on a souvent parlé sur ce plateau
de cette championne et notamment sur
deux sur la suite la préparation et la
suite des jo ou
où ça ne s'est pas passé exactement
comme comme elle le souhaitait on en
parlait aussi d'elle comme porte-drapeau
donc il ya un ensemble de un ensemble de
d'éléments qui ont qui ont été peut-être
d'aider des espoirs audéoud et des
éléments positifs qu'elle a eue qu'elle
a eu en tête dans la gestion de sa
carrière et que et que finalement comme
ça ne s'est pas passé comme prévu et
notamment sur le ring qui est un
ensemble de ces de frustration où elle
est peut-être comme beaucoup de boxeuse
ou deux boxeurs assez sanguine assez
assez spontané et ça peut expliquer
justement c'est ce type de haut de
réaction à l'emporte-pièce en tout cas
pour une championne comme celle là mieux
vaut pour la fin de sa carrière avoir le
choix dans la date et pouvoir repartir
justement sur des annonces
sur des fermes claires et pouvoir
justement gérer la fin de sa carrière le
nigeria
la boxe enfin j'ai jamais dit que je me
parlerait plus de boxe après après
l'émission après les jeux olympiques et
les décisions arbitrales qui qui
commence à m'énerver maintenant là je
vais on va plus parler d'eux de l'esprit
de champion est donc en effet il ya un
moment où
c'est quand même un sport où ils font
très peu de combattants mené ces trois
quatre combats par an donc c'est des
préparations deux mois et demi trois
mois à chaque fois avec des sèche avec
des phases difficiles de travail donc
donc je peux comprendre que que la voilà
elle en est elle qu elles puissent en
avoir une qu'elle puisse avoir une soeur
coude ras-le-bol sur une décision
supplémentaires entre guillemets la
goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le vase
et d'avoir balancé ça et de l'avoir
regretté très rapidement derrière et
c'est pas la première et ce n'est pas la
première et ça arrivera encore mais
voilà c'est
cdc des années de préparation et des
déceptions maintenant voilà quand même
eu de très belles de très belles choses
dans sa carrière donc il faut garder le
positif et voir le positif pour pouvoir
continuer d'avancer encore
dia le jour où on enregistre cette
émission elle a publié un tweet là donc
il va rester dans le cas de son cirque
livre ouais dit voilà c'est la
récompense va être un très grand fan de
bail va mettre ça grégory on en a parlé
souvent son double parcours et les
policières aussi dans sa vie
professionnelle elle a dit que les aléas
du ring peuvent parfois être plus
compliqué à gérer que le combat en lui
même mais là ça revient sur sur ce qu'on
disait et c'est une humaine avant tout
elle peut aussi parfois avoir des coûts
nous était un câble c'est de toute façon
aussi la cette prédominance des réseaux
sociaux dans l'univers des sportifs
maintenant on en parlait il ya pas si
longtemps il ya quinze jours et 15 jours
avant ou où justement ils ont désormais
des tribunes d'une part mais surtout ils
sont énormément exposés et donc c'est
une utilisation très simple très simple
très simple
une dizaine de minutes déjà un article
sur saône et julia nationale elle
pensait sûrement pour ça il va exprimer
exprimer ah c'est que pas une
nous finalement ça se retrouve exposé
partout et on en parle jusqu'à ce
plateau là donc c'est évidemment une
exposition internationale sur ce plateau
est donc justement cc7 cette
prédominance de la tribune réseaux
sociaux qui fait que maintenant il faut
il faut tourner sept fois sa langue dans
sa bouche est dense et dans ces petites
avant d'avoir deux tweeté ou de poster
mais est ce que ça peut pas la desservir
peut-être pour la suite de sa carrière
ce qui s'est passé c'est
pas une légende
on peut se dire que c'est une fille qui
peut dérailler assez facilement sur les
réseaux sociaux peut-être non non non
non non non mais non parce que là on
fait ce métier
c'est pas non plus
parce qu on la croira quand il voudra
vraiment arrêté sa carrière tout ça la
clé sera le fera elle fera vraiment les
choses dans
l'immédiat rien dialysés j'arrête ma
carrière
ça se serait passé inaperçu et dit
j'arrête ma carrière sur le petit tweet
comme ça pour rigoler ou surtout renvoyé
à
ses copines et biba
finir égaré ses priorités dans les
historiques privés plus tôt
envoie des messages perso j'ai connu les
deux ans justement elle peut mesurer à
ce point là son degré de popularité
peut-être justement sur la ciotat sur
l'audience qui a été donné il sur elle
et sur les routes où elle voit que vous
avez sur cette annonce parce c'est
peut-être anodine et finalement fakara
d'odyssud mais il a trouvé un coup de
pub et l'or pour voir un petit peu ou
alan était au niveau popularité
imagine
mais quand même elle aura pu mesurer sa
popularité à travers un tweet qui a duré
un quart d'heure en plus elle à ces
jeunes maiva hamadouche 32 ans mais elle
peut encore continuer quelques années
grégory bon le pour moi le gros est
plutôt derrière mais il ya encore de
belles années et il ya
notamment une échéance alors en dehors
des combats professionnels il ya eu
cette première expérience audio même si
elle est amère pour elle parce qu'elle a
perdu lors de ce premier combat je pense
qu'elle a envie de récidiver et il ya
une échéance olympique à paris voilà
forcément c'est dans un coin de sa tête
il peut être très lente est peut-être
aussi à paris peut-être aux mains dans
les porte drapeaux
je pense que c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission alors merci à toi t'as vu les
là-dessus alors aujourd'hui font peser
jusqu'à sion de l'ancien footballeur et
entraîneur luis fernandes le succès n'a
pas besoin d'explications l'échec na
n'est pas de justification je vous
laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
oui